this was massive a mini budget turned
Maxi the biggest tax cuts in half a
century a brand new economic bar can we
afford these tax cuts Chancellor in a
huge gamble for growth
a conservative Chancellor ripping up his
predecessor's rulebook
we need a new approach for a new era
our aim over the medium term is to reach
a trend rate of growth of 2.5 with that
aim came a stream of measures staggering
in size and significance next year's
planned increase in cooperation tax will
be canceled the increase in employer
National Insurance contributions and
dividends tax will be canceled
clear boost for business
a Chancellor pleased with himself and
with an attempt to please the city too
scrap in the cap on Bankers bonuses we
need Global Banks to create jobs here
invest here and pay taxes here in London
in London not in Paris not in Frankfurt
and not in New York the cabinet in
agreement the PM poker faced but this
mini budget shock and all Mr Speaker
I have another measure tax cuts Galore
with one big surprise the 45 Pence top
rate of tax scrapped I'm not going to
cut the additional rate of tax today Mr
Speaker
I'm going to abolish it all together
from April the 23rd
[Applause]
but something for everyone else too I
can announce today that we will cut the
basic rate of income tax to 19 pence in
April 2023 one year early that means the
tax cut for over 31 million people in
just a few months time this a government
in office but weeks rewriting budgets of
Tory Chancellor's past balancing the
books giving way to tax cuts and
borrowing
a new era for labor jiren and jibin
typical to this Commons chamber but
these Economic Times far from typical
where have the last 12 years left us
lower growth lower investment lower
productivity and today we learn that we
have the lowest consumer confidence
since records began the only things that
are going up are inflation interest
rates and bankers bonuses
[Applause]
I'm borrowing
not having any of it but it is that
borrowing causing concern on the PM's
own back benches growth and cutting
attacks is our true conservative
principles yeah so he's balancing the
books
by my calculations the uh deficit this
year based on his announcements will be
in the region of 250 billion pounds
and this man in the treasury just months
ago is not so sure either clearly there
is an immediate cost but the value in
terms of the growth and the revenues
that will come are at the moment uh a a
presumption the government just added 70
billion pounds to the deficit in one
swoop these are significant sums of
money
of course it worries me the cost of
borrowing the uncertainty around the
increasing cost of borrowing this is a
hugely significant fiscal event not just
in the substance of the borrowing and
tax cuts but in the politics of turning
the conservative party consensus on how
to run the economy on its head Liz truss
backers told me that there was no other
option that they have to go all out for
economic growth but her detractors are
worried that she could trash the
conservative party brand and cost them
the next election one MP said to me I'm
scared I'm worried they're going to tank
the economy so so this party very splits
on the plan but what everyone can agree
on is that it's a huge political risk
this a Chancellor in the job just weeks
announcing policies and tax cuts not
seen for decades both the PM and
Chancellor this afternoon out of London
with business there will come a point
where it's not just business that
matters but ordinary voters to Bath
Rigby Sky News and Westminster